can you compare the style of doing
science in the States and in Europe yes
sir similarity is in some ways a
different style of course science is so
international nowadays that we all need
conferences we visit each other and it's
no longer isolated the US and Europe
nonetheless of course the styles are a
little bit different at Stanford of
course that was a hotbed of the creation
of Silicon Valley a lot of interesting
people and a lot of excitement about
innovation in Germany at least I think
innovation people are at first skeptical
they feel life is good the way it is why
do you want to innovated so the spirit
is at least of the general public is
maybe not so enticing for doing research
but of course we live in our own world
in our circle of students and colleagues
who share our excitement and and one
thing that actually might be better in
Germany at least in the Max Planck
societies that for basic research we
don't have to declare what we are going
to do next year or the year after that
but but we we have a stable level of
support quite comfortable that makes it
possible to pursue also risky long-term
research project
you